uh benign overfitting kind of continuing
from what not he was talking about in
his last tutorial and our first speaker
for this afternoon is going to be in the
logic chatterjee who is a postdoc at
stanford and got his phd here at
berkeley uh just last year so really
excited to hear your talk
thanks spencer and thanks to all the
organizers for
organizing this really nice workshop and
also for the invitation
today i'm going to continue talking
about uh some results about
interpolating models so this like ngati
stock was a great introduction to
everything i'm going to talk about so
hopefully it sets up the background
really nicely
this is joint work with tatsu who's one
of my postdoctoral advisors sam and alex
who are grad students at stanford were
really excellent and phil who is at
google research
so
the
the setting for the talk is these set of
experiments that ngati talked about and
also alluded to throughout his
tutorial today morning we've seen these
set of experiments that show that deep
networks tend to generalize well
even when your data your training data
has missed classification noise your
model is vastly over parametrized so the
number of parameters in your model is is
much larger than the number of data
points
uh you're using training methods that
aren't explicitly regularized uh on you
aren't really early stopping too early
and you're training to almost or nearly
zero training loss via some gradient
based method
um so these set of experiments were both
surprising and this has led to sort of
many people in this room sort of trying
to investigate why networks tend to
generalize despite sort of
seemingly over fitting to the noise and
and it is a surprising statistical
phenomenon
but
another reason is
uh interpolating the data is often quite
beneficial so there are multiple
experiments that show
uh that when you're in this
interpolating regime that is when you
have many
many more parameters than number of data
points your test error is often lower
and it's actually beneficial to sort of
interpolate the data
um however i should point out that like
most of these sort of experimental
observations are sort of in in the
following setting
typically the training data that the
distribution of your training data is
sort of very well aligned with the
distribution of your test data so you
have no shift between
the distributions from training to test
time
and secondly you're usually looking at
sort of dense models that are trained by
some gradient based method on the
squared or cross entropy class so
usually it's in this sort of um
standard setting of machine learning
where you have no shift between uh your
train and test data and your your
training sort of standard sort of
resonate kind of models
using hdd
so what i'm going to talk about today is
what happens when we veer off sort of
the standard machine learning setting
where we have
no distribution shift and we're training
dense models and and ask what happens to
interpolating models there
so so the first sort of setting that
we're going to look at is what happens
to interpolating classifiers when you
have a shift from training to test time
this is something that's being explored
by the machine learning community quite
uh
by a lot of people over the past few
years
and sort of one sort of data set that's
often used is the celeb a data set so
during test time you have these common
groups in the training data so here
you're trying to identify let's say the
hair color of the celebrity whether it's
blonde or dark and you have sort of
these groups where you have lots of
pictures in the training group where you
have people with blonde hair that are
female and people with dark hair that
are male
but you also have these atypical groups
in your training set where you have
sort of people who are male with blonde
hair but you see a very
small fraction of this in your training
set
so usually your training set is an
imbalanced mixture of these groups
however you could think of a situation
where and in fact the test set is such
that it's a uniform mixture over all of
these groups so you can see
during test time you could equally
likely see a sample from each of these
groups
so what happens if you learn
interpolating classifiers in the
presence of distribution shift so you
could look at a loss function that tries
to correct for this shift so you could
rewrite sort of these atypical points a
lot more and you could train until
interpolation
so the curve that we're going to look at
is error versus resonant width and
resonant width is sort of a proxy for
how many parameters that we have
we find that as we start like increasing
the width and interpolating the data the
error on this worst group so these
atypical examples during test time it
starts to rise
so we see that because the error on
these atypical groups is riding rising
the test error the overall test error
which is a uniform mixture over these
groups is also going to rise
uh so we see that and and we have seen
this like people have found this across
a whole bunch of settings this is just
an example i'm giving you with celeb a
uh people have found this to be true
across lots of training methods and data
sets as well
abating the cross entropy loss is often
ineffective
and in fact to see why rewaiting fails
we don't even have to look at neural
networks here's a toy data example where
i have a minority group so these blue
points are
the minority group and you have many
points from the majority group and
you're trying to learn the max margin
classifier which is this dotted line
if you run gradient descent
on the unweighted objective which is
just the common weighted cross entropy
objective versus whether you re-weighted
you tend to learn the same classifier as
you start to interpolate the data
okay so it seems like rebating is
seemingly incompatible with
interpolation and it's it's not quite
clear whether
we can get whether rewaiting is an
effective sort of robustness
intervention when we are interpolating
the data
so that's the first sort of path that
we're going to wear off the second thing
i'm going to talk about is past models
so as ngati alluded to in his tutorial
again we've been seeing sort of models
that have been scaling and again they've
been uh leading to sort of big gains in
terms of uh downstream accuracy
however this comes at the cost of added
memory and inference time as these
models are getting large even taking a
forward pass through these models is
getting um pretty challenging
uh and and people have started looking
at sort of what happens if you train
sparse or model so one example i'd like
to give you from
uh the domain of nlp is people have been
training large language models that have
been sort of
been
very good over the past few years and
they're they're huge models and even
doing inference of them on them is is
sort of sometimes prohibitively
expensive uh so people have been looking
at sort of sparse mixture of expert
models which are still large models but
are much more efficient in terms of
both inference times and
and
sort of power efficiency
um
so you can ask you you may want to train
sparser models but how does that sort of
affect the test error
um
again i'm going to show you a plot where
i have error versus the number of uh the
width which is going to be a proxy for
number of parameters
we see as you you start to train when
you start to train dense models you see
sort of the error go down as you
increase the over parameterization
but as you start and to learn sparser
and sparser networks the test error is
definitely higher so as you learn
sparser networks even when you're
interpolating the data
the test error tends to degrade
so the next question that we ask is if
you're trying to learn sparse networks
are you and you're interpolating the
data are you always going to suffer
higher error than if you were to learn a
dense model
um so those are the two questions that
we're going to address and let me give
you uh
so that's going to be
uh the two topics that we very often do
we're going to study both of these
non-standard settings again with the
humble linear model and hopefully
build both algorithmic insight and maybe
uh
try and draw conclusions
for what's happening with neural
networks
the first one was going to be about
interpolation and distribution shift and
the second one explores the interplay
between sparsity and interpolation
so with that let's get started about
interpolating classifiers with
importance waiting
so the setting for the talk is going to
be binary classification with
distribution shifts so we have n data
points the features are in rd and the
labels are binary so they're plus minus
one drawn from some distribution b train
okay
so think of like the celebi example
where you have many maybe examples from
these common groups but few examples
from this atypical group
during but your goal is to minimize the
test error on a different test
distribution so your samples are going
to be drawn from a different
distribution in this case it was a
uniform mixture over these things
um
so given that this is your goal instead
of minimizing sort of the standard
logistic loss you could try and minimize
the importance weighted logistic loss so
you could associate it with sample i you
could take your logistic loss and
reweight them by wi
so a standard sort of classical choice
to do this is to rewrite them using the
density ratio between the test and drain
distribution
okay so why would you want to do this if
you abbreviate it in this way then
after rewaiting this rebated loss
function is an unbiased estimate of your
test loss so it seems like a reasonable
thing to do
and then once you have this sort of
re-weighted loss you could train up
until interpolation
we've already seen with the entropy this
doesn't work right even with linear
classifiers in this example that i
showed you if you were to rebate versus
not rewrite
you learn the same boundary and in fact
there's theory that shows that this
fails and you can do experiments with
neural networks and also see that this
is essential you essentially learn the
same decision boundary even when you
minimize the deviated loss with neural
networks
and people have also shown that early
stopping or regularization sort of helps
these are results
about what happens when you start to
interpolate the data but you do take
different paths
to that interference
um so the question is can we design
interpolators that respond to repeating
that is can be sort of build over
parameterized classifiers that
that
sort of have all of the benefits that we
see with over parameterization in the
standard iid setting but also
have them respond to rewaiting
so to do that we first want to
understand why sort of exponentially
tailed losses like the cross entropy or
the logistic laws fail
so we're going to consider
linearly separable data
x 1 y 1 up to x and y n we're going to
look at linear classifiers the
classifier is just x i transpose theta
and we are minimizing this rewaited loss
if you look at the iterates of gradient
descent with step size eta if your step
size is small enough past sort of
theoretical result shows that the
direction of this classifier like you
have to look at the direction because
then the iterates are going off to
infinity but the direction of this
classifier in fact goes to the max
margin classifier
one thing to notice is
this asymptotic direction does not
depend on the weights wa so you could
have set these weights any way you
wanted asymptotically you're going to
the same max margin classifier
yeah
that's a bit weird it feels like we have
set these weights in we were hoping that
these weights would have an effect but
at least while we interpolate the data
it plays no effect so what's an
intuitive way to understand this
um so we have this related objective how
we could sort of interpret this related
objective is
we create sort of a new data set where
we take sample i and we repeated w i
times let's think of w i as being an
integer so you can just repeat the
sample i w i times
uh so now you've created this new data
set and you could and this is like the
standard loss function on that data set
you you don't have to reweight it
uh the max margin classifier on this new
data set is unchanged right you have
repeated the constraint for the max
margin classifier wi times but that's
that's not going to change
what the max margin classifier is and
now you can just use sort of the
um
the usual implicit bias results that
ngati talked about
that tell you that gradient descent with
small enough step size converges in
direction to the max margin classifier
for the logistic loss and and conclude
that rewaiting also doesn't get you
anything
so
hopefully that conveys the intuition for
why exponentially tall tail losses fail
so the first proposal is to switch
losses so you can look at the proof of
why sort of the
implicit bias is the same and you find
that it's really down to the sort of
loss function decaying exponentially
quickly in the margin and and and sort
of the proposal is simple if you want
re-weighting to work you you kind of
need the loss function to decay sort of
more slowly with the margin and here we
say you should have them decay
polynomially
let me quickly show you that this at
least works in this sort of toy example
so in this toy data setting that i've
been carrying around when you sort of
use the
polynomially tailed classifier loss with
importance weighting you recover the
right boundary and that's good at least
it works in toy examples
but what's its implicit bias right
so
let's say we have again linearly
separable data and now we have a loss
function that we have designed
differently so it's like the logistic
loss when the margin is small
but once the margin starts getting large
it decays polynomial here it decays as
one over the margin to the alpha
okay
now again you run the iterates of
gradient descent with small enough step
size and you find that the direction now
converges to something different this
converges in direction to something we
call the polytail classifier theta alpha
here you see that it it kind of does
depend on the weights so that's a good
sign so what you can think of as doing
is you're fitting all data points
correctly
and then you're
trying to maximize the margin uh
trying to maximize this weighted margin
so think about if you have two groups
one is a minority group and one is a
majority group on the minority groups
you will have said wi to be large
so
on those groups the
margin this this classifier will try and
make them it will try and uh get a
higher margin on those points okay so at
least intuitively it feels like where
you set the weights to be higher you'll
try and achieve higher margin
um
and i should point out that this really
builds up on some really nice results by
way matus miro and rob where they
studied the implicit bias of polytail
classifiers and we adapted that here for
to study weighted losses
so
at least sorry go on what is alpha in
the previous slide
alpha is just think of it as
it holds for any alpha
so
is it related to how the tail behaves or
something like that yeah alpha controls
how
the the decay of the tail so so if you
said think about alpha equals one it
says that the tail behaves as one over
the margin
and um
so
the i guess here you're talking about
like gradient in the entire dataset do
you think uh even with bounced gradient
pre-weighting won't fail
um
i think
at least empirically it doesn't seem to
hurt and i think
if i
understand correctly at least for the
logistic loss i think the implicit bias
remains the same
uh when you have stochastic gradient
design versus full batch gradient
descent so
at least there it won't hurt yeah
so the previous results that i said that
you can just invoke previous results
even if you were to invoke it for sgd i
think you'll get the same
[Music]
it doesn't need to be greater than one
you have to ensure that the loss is
convex and decreasing and that's it yeah
alpha yeah as long as you sort of stitch
the loss together such that
satisfies that you can have
uh i think we need differentiability
but i'm not sure if that's crucial but
yeah let's say we need the friendship
video
i'm wondering if
something like changing the exponential
asset different ways like could i have
done e to the minus
you know to give like a different way
right like it's clear the wi in front
doesn't
like
is it clear that somehow a
multiplicative shift
i think that's that feels like more
correct yeah yeah so if you want uh
sticking to sort of
uh
classical debating algorithm where you
debate the loss and you start to fiddle
with the exponents of the uh yeah then
the implicit bias will change
um i think
while that would change the implicit
bias i think one thing that's trickier
is how do you set
sort of those exponents correctly yeah
and i think
loss which is valid for somehow
i was thinking of demand larger margin
for some cis like a margin would be
proportional to one overseas
the proposal if i understand correctly
is to use a different ci for every
sample so you said that yeah
[Music]
i
yes just a quick comment regarding the
multiplicative factor
i think at least in the linear case uh i
believe that
depending on the margins the ratio of
the two margins that will bond
we can
is
good so
so right so we have built a loss
function that at least asymptotically uh
responds to relating but you could ask
what about the test performance right
like uh we've changed the implicit bias
we have
um
we've got something that depends on the
weights how does it perform
uh so that's what's coming next so we're
going to study a setting where the
polytail classifier achieves minimax
accuracy
uh whereas we're going to show a lower
bound in the same setting where the max
margin classifier what you'd get
by minimizing sort of abbreviated
exponentially tailed loss uh fails
um what's this setting going to be it's
going to be a setting where we have uh
it's a label shift setting so we have
two uh classes
and a class conditional
class conditional distribution
corresponding to each class so you have
a majority class
let's say that are associated with
labels plus one
uh you have uh the features for this
majority class are drawn from
a normal with let's say mean mu 1 and
variance identity this can be sort of
relaxed to subversion distributions but
for this talk let's just think of
the class conditionals being normal
and you then you have a minority class
where you have labels minus one
and you have features that are drawn
from mu2 and
variant mean mu2 and covariance identity
okay so in the training data we're going
to have skewed training data so we're
going to have a lot more samples from
the positive class than the negative
class and tau is going to be the ratio
between the number of positive samples
by negative samples
so as tau gets larger your training data
is more and more skewed
and the test error is going to be a
uniform mixture from both of these
classes
we're going to make some assumptions on
the data we're going to assume n is
larger than log one over delta where
delta is the failure probability
uh the scale of the separation which is
norm of mu is going to be larger than n
squared times log factors and we're
going to be in the high dimensional
setting where d is larger than n times
norm of mu squared
okay and we're going to set uh we're
going to minimize reweighted losses so
the way that we we're going to set the
weights is we're going to set it equal
to one if your sample comes from the
positive class that is if it has label
one and we're going to set it equal to
some w which i'll specify in a moment
which is greater than one if it comes
from the minority class
okay
uh
so for this model if the loss decays as
one over z so we have fixed alpha to be
1 here
and if your failure probability is less
than a constant
and if you set your weights in this sort
of beard way where you said w to scale
with tau cube so you want to set w
e to scale with tau cube which is where
tau was sort of the imbalance ratio
then with probability one minus delta
the test error of this polynomially tail
classifier decreases exponentially in
the number of minority group samples
times norm of mu to the 4 divided by d
the dimension
this is known to be sort of minimax
optimal
in this problem and and you know if this
thing is all going off to infinity your
test error is going to zero
so that's an upper bound on the
performance of the polynomially tailed
classifier
and further we show that if your
imbalance is sufficiently large then
with probability at least one minus
delta the test error of the max margin
is at least a constant
okay so here's a setting where this
could go off to infinity and the test
error could go to zero but
uh if you use sort of an exponentially
tailed loss your test error is lower
bounded by a constant
um just to instantiate this with the
setting so say norm of mu the number of
samples in the minority group and tau
are scaling this way with d don't worry
about the exact exponents this is just
as an example
uh as d goes off to infinity and all of
these sort of problem parameters are
scaling appropriately
you have this sort of strict separation
between the test performance of
the max margin classifier as and the
polynomially tailored class
okay so first thing is why set the
weights this way so i i sort of
specified a pretty unusual choice for
the weights so i i asked you to set the
weights as tau cube that's not a
standard choice so
um the if you think about this if you
said w equals tau cube the resulting
sort of loss that you get is uh is is
biased it's not an unbiased estimate of
the test loss
uh the sort of classical choice that you
have in in sort of classical statistics
tells you that you should say w equals
to tau this results in sort of
an unbiased training loss
um and further there's nothing special
about tau cube i should point out that
if l scales as one over z to the alpha
then you have a a theory prescribes a
different setting for w in terms of
alpha so
we're going to dig deeper into why we
set w this way
uh firstly let me just show you in the
setting that w equals tau cube is maybe
the right way to set the weights
so i'm going to show you some
simulations where i'm going to show you
the test error versus the imbalance
ratio so as i vary as i as the imbalance
ratio gets larger the problem is getting
harder
you can look at the performance of
the max margin classifier and the poly
tail classifier when you don't have any
importance waiting and the test error
gets larger as you'd expect
secondly if you use the polytail
classifier but you use sort of the
classical importance weights uh you you
see that the test error is definitely
lower but
um
uh it is still rising as sort of the
imbalance gets worse and finally when
sort of
you said w equal to tau cube here your
test error essentially remains fat as
your problem gets harder
another way to see this is you look at
the test error versus row where row is
this exponent of tau so we're going to
set w equal to tau to the row
we can look at the decomposition between
minority group error and the majority
group error so
the light blue line shows sort of the
test error of the minority group samples
and we see that like even when we set it
equal to tau um your minority group
samples uh suffer higher error than
you'd want it to
whereas when you set it equal to tau
cube and really over correct on these
minority group samples you you suffer
low overall error
so hopefully this simulation is is
convincing uh next i'd like to step
through
just sort of the key ingredients of the
proof to maybe convince you that why we
get this w equals tau and also point out
uh
some ideas that we
that we have to use
uh firstly uh
you know by half things inequality you
you get that the test error at infinity
is is upper bounded by uh these
quantities that involve what we call the
normalized margins yes
you change the words
[Music]
it depends how you change the data set
yeah typically yes so in sort of real
experiments that i'll show you later
that's a hyper parameter that we choose
of the validation set
uh
i don't think we tried simulations where
we varied
these toy distributions around but my
guess would be
but i think the important thing to take
away is that
you you like
we never found that the classical
important states of setting w equals tau
was kind of the right thing
right
so
the test error uh we're looking at the
test error and we see that you can bound
it in terms of these normalized margins
which essentially is the inner product
between
theta and
the means mu 1 and mu 2 divided by norm
of theta squared
so if sort of we could track how these
normalized margins evolve
we could sort of get a bound on the test
error
you can sort of write down how these
normalized margin revolves as a function
of t which is the iteration count
and and you see sort of two things one
is the
the the red term here kind of
is the right quantity if we could show
that this blue term that we have here in
a bracket
if this is a constant we'd kind of be
done because
then we'd have showed that the
normalized margin is lower bounded by
the number of minority group samples
times the signal strength by square root
t and that's kind of what we want to get
our upper bound
and to do this we kind of need to show
that
to show that this blue term is constant
we kind of need to show that the
numerator is lower bounded
so the key sort of ingredient to show
that this numerator is upper bounded is
what we call the loss ratio bound which
sort of is useful in a variety of
problems apart from this one
uh which kind of shows the following it
shows that if the step size is small
enough then for all iterations s of
gradient descent
for all sample pairs i and j
the ratio of the losses is upper bounded
by some constant times the inverse ratio
of the weights on those points raised to
a third
okay so if you think about what this is
telling you it's telling you that if
your samples are coming from the same
group then the losses of those samples
sort of reduce at the same rate as
training goes on
and if your samples come from differing
groups then it's bounded as a function
of the weights from those groups
and essentially if you sort of use this
loss ratio bound to lower bound the
numerator and you know do a bit of
algebra you can show that the numerator
is lower bounded by some function of the
denominator
um
so yeah so the crucial thing i like i
want you to take away is if you can show
that the loss ratios are bounded that is
your training algorithm reduces the loss
on all points equally you can sort of
plug that in and show bounds on the
normalization
um so we did a bunch of sort of theory
with linear models and and we found sort
of two things one is using polynomially
tail losses and the second was over
correcting with the importance weights
we could see how this translates to sort
of experiments with neural networks
firstly if you look at sort of
interpolating models and we look at the
celeb a data set we see that
firstly if you use polynomially tail
losses
compared to the cross entropy loss you
definitely see sort of gains and
accuracy
and secondly if you exponentiate the
weights you you see sort of the
gains improve further even as you start
to interpolate the data whereas for the
cross entropy loss sort of the
accuracy essentially remains the same
whether you relate or don't rewrite as
sort of theory kind of predicts yeah
sorry
early stopping does help so that's
exactly
the next plot here so if you do early
stop you see
um uh sort of
using the cross entropy loss does lead
to better accuracy
uh but often like using the polynomially
tail loss and od stopping helps even
further
so early stopping still does help but
like using switching to the polynomial
detailed
still seems to help
um and so this was comparisons with
cross-entropy loss there are other sort
of stronger rewaiting methods that
people have proposed in the literature
uh yes uh if you go back to the last
slide did you try already stopping with
data set
yes
yeah yeah so this is like i'm showing
you that was for celebrity this was for
seafarer yeah
we do have experiments with syllabi and
well and like
the trends are similar
okay
um yeah you can compare to other
stronger rewaiting baselines that people
have proposed for these group shift
problems uh we find that like it's
almost always as good or better than
other sort of rewaiting methods proposed
and
finally i'd also want to say that there
are other more sophisticated sort of
uh distributionally robust optimization
methods that people have proposed and
you can plug in the polynomial retail
loss into that
and and you also see gains in accuracy
um
so with this i'd like to finish the
first part and just highlight the
takeaways one is sort of robustness
interventions behave quite differently
in the interpolation regime so sort of
importance weighting
doesn't help for the cross entropy loss
once you start interpolating the data
but you do it does help if you use the
polynomial tail loss and sort of
studying this theoretically and figuring
out the right implicit bias is useful
finally
sort of careful theoretical analysis
even with toy models often can lead to
non-intuitive algorithmic
ideas and
at least in this case we found that it
was useful and translated over the
neural network experiments as well
yes
um
i mean
so
i guess the idea is if you look at the
like the test error you find that
um the losses on sort of uh you you
essentially want like the losses on the
two groups
to reduce at the same rate so that they
influence your classifier the same
amount as training goes on
so that was what the loss ratio bond was
showing it was bounding how much the
loss on sample from one group uh
compares to a loss from uh sort of
i thought it was the gradient
the gradient should be equal and here
it's like the loss is related to the
gradient yeah
so yeah you can think about the
gradients to be equal
yeah
uh
essentially yeah you you want like the
losses to decrease at the same rate so
that like so imagine if the losses on
the minority groups was to reduce too
quickly
then latent training all your classifier
would only learn from the majority group
points if you just look at how the
gradient if your loss is too small it
won't like influence how the classifier
is updated
so essentially keeping the loss ratio
roughly constant helps
you want to keep it constant across the
entire yeah
yes
modify this for like if you have like
here it's a binary class problem so yeah
one ratio and
you got it
um i think in terms of the theory it
should be uh
sort of
i mean we didn't try it but i expect you
can sort of take this model create a
multi-class version and sort of proceed
we didn't try multi-class sort of neural
network experiments so i'm like
no if that's the question i'm not sure
what's the
right way to select the weights but i
probably guess also
okay so
that's the uh first part of the talk uh
second i'm going to talk about sort of
the interplay between
sparsity and interpolation so just to
remind you we we've seen these
experiments
where
you can interpolate the data and if you
have a sparser model the test error
seems to be higher uh again we're going
to try and understand this with linear
uh models and and and we're going to
study sparsity in linear regression
so here the setting is going to be the
following where we have n data points
y's are now not labels they're sort of
real
uh we're going to be in a setting where
x i is
d dimensional where d is much larger
than n so you're in the over
parameterized regime
and the y's are related to the x's as
follows so you have a true theta star so
y is equal to x i transpose theta star
plus some noise
and we want to think of a setting where
theta star is case pass so the
underlying truth is case pass and you
want to think about are there
interpolants that can sort of leverage
this underlying sparsity
um
so how we are going to do this is ask us
the following questions we want to ask
how does the excess risk of a sparse
interpolator behave
so a
canonical sparse interpolator to keep in
mind is the minimum l1 norm interpolant
um it's it's literally you minimize the
l1 norm subject to fitting the data
uh this is also called basis pursuit and
and as ngati i think briefly talked
about it in the tutorial this is known
to sort of promote sparsity and there's
your decades of literature on this
so that's a canonical sparse
interpolator to keep in mind
uh and and you could ask how does this
pass interpolant compared to sort of
dense interference so if you think about
the minimum l2 norm
interpolant it's likely to be dense
we have sort of bounds on
the excess risk of the minimum l2 norm
and you could ask how how does the
excess risk of the minimum l1 norm
compare to
it uh we we like given that i have posed
two questions i better have an answer so
we we kind of show that sparsity is in
fact incompatible with interpolating
noisy data and we show this via a lower
bound on the excess risk
how do we construct this lower bound so
say you have these data points
generating in this way
we're going to assume that the
coordinates of the
covariates are drawn from a normal
distribution with zero mean and
covariance sigma
sigma is going to have this very
particular structure which we call the k
epsilon model
so your you have k it's it's going to be
diagonal
your first k directions are going to
have variance one your last d minus k
directions are going to have variance
epsilon and think of epsilon as being
smaller than one
so it's it has this very nice uh sort of
spike structure
the noise is drawn
independently
of the data and it's it's drawn from a
normal with zero mean and variance sigma
squared
and the true model is case pass
right
yes
i don't but like people in this room do
yeah
yeah at least with isotropic covariance
there are there are a bunch of like
really nice results who's the question
[Music]
hey do you want i mean this is like
essentially saying that you're like oh
dimensional item you have some
isotropic does the l1 interpolant doing
well
we can look at the lower bound and like
maybe that will make it
um so here's a lower bound for the
excess risk and this is a lower bound
for any sparse linear interpolator
so if the failure probability is a
constant if the noise variance is sort
of comparable to the norm of theta star
and d is larger than n and n is larger
than
k which is the sparsity
uh
raised to the one plus constant
then with probability one minus delta
for any s pass interpolant
the excess risk of it is lower bounded
by sigma squared n divided by s log
squared d over s
okay
so the excess risk here is uh for this
problem is just theta of s minus theta
star which is this true underlying model
measured with respect to the sigma norm
squared
um
we see as your model gets more and more
sparse so um this lower bound gets
larger so your excess
risk could be larger is lower bounded by
something larger and in the numerator
you have sigma squared n which you could
think of as how much noise do you have
in your training data so it's it's
essentially saying your excess risk is
at least sigma squared n divided by s
and i should also mention that there was
a
similar lower bound derived by
muthukumar at all in the isotropic case
where epsilons were are just one
so just to
sort of flesh out what this bond is
telling us so you could have sparsity
level starting from k which is the
sparsity of the underlying model
n and d where d is just corresponding to
the positive dense model this lower
bound says that the excess risk of the
sparse model is lower bounded by
something larger than the excess risk of
a dense model
so what does this mean about the minimum
l1 norm interpolant
we know that in the setting basis
pursuit
outputs and ends past simulation almost
surely
this is you can look at one of the many
papers in the literature and this is a
fact about the basis pursuit that's
known
uh so if you can plug this if if your s
is equal to n this tells us that the
excess risk is lower bounded by
something that sigma squared divided by
log d over n
so it's only decreasing logarithmically
in d so you can think of d growing and
and this is only going down
logarithmically
and okay so why is this bad so consider
a case where i set the parameters of the
problem in this way and this is an
example
uh so i can set the sparsity level to be
square root n i could say d equals n
squared let's say epsilon which is like
the variance of the small directions as
one over n squared and i could set like
the noise variance and theta star as a
constant
this says that sort of previous results
tell us that the
risk of
the ols solution or the minimum l2 norm
solution goes down as one over n in this
case however for the minimum l1 norm
solution it's lower bounded by
something that's logarithmically in it
just goes down logarithmically in it
in fact
even though the ground truth is fast the
risk of the l1 norm interpolant can be
exponentially uh worse
yes
[Applause]
uh for the ols yes so in this paper that
i uh
sort of cited here by peter
alex gabor and phil they have a lower
bound
at least on the variance of uh
of
of the
estimator
and
at least actually there are upper bounds
for the l1 norm solution there are upper
bounds for
the minimum l1 norm solution in the
isotropic case
uh by
uh
by nadi and and uh friedrich and lisa
and danica and constantine and fanny and
co-authors also yeah so there are upper
bounds in multiple settings that all
sort of go down i think
logarithmically and
in the isotropic case i think the upper
and lower bounds almost match up to sort
of i think a square root log n factor
but yeah
good so
um
yeah and and let me just spend like
uh
a quick slide on the intuition before
uh
yeah so the energy of the noise scales
as sigma squared n so we know norm of y
squared scales us sigma squared n
because you have
n independent sort of noise you have
noise added to each sample
dense interpolators sort of can spread
this over d directions so if you think
about the interpolation equation you
have you need to have y is equal to x
theta
in for the ols
you can spread this over many
unimportant directions and this is kind
of the intuition that sort of baked in
and talked about in in these papers that
derive the upper bounds uh you you can
sort of spread the effect of the noise
in these many unimportant directions you
you can fit the noise using this
directions and it doesn't hurt you in
terms of the risk
however if you look at sparse estimators
like basis pursuit it can only use
a
smaller number of directions to sort of
hide this noise which is why it suffers
higher risk
um
okay so i finally want to end
with just a summary and highlight some
open questions
uh firstly we talked about importance
waiting and interpolation
we saw that robustness interventions
tend to behave in weird ways
uh in the interpolation regime and it's
sort of uh interesting to sort of design
uh algorithms that sort of work uh
uh in this regime
and also that sometimes the solutions
can be non-intuitive like in this case
we had to have
weights that were exponentiated and
needed loss functions that were biased
we also talked about the interplay
between sparsity and interpolation
it's i think sort of interesting to ask
if there are other
properties like sparsity that are either
aligned or misaligned with
generalization in this regime
and finally i mean i i showed sort of
experiments with neural networks where
seemingly sparsity is harmful
we did so we showed lower bounds with
linear models and uh
i have no clue how to prove this for
neural networks but it'll be interesting
to understand if
uh sparsity is also sort of
fundamentally harmful when you are
fitting noise with neural networks
with that i'd like to thank my
collaborators once again tatsu sam phil
and alex and yeah happy to take
questions
thank you for the talk do we have some
time for questions if anyone
has any
i mean so what role does the name
function play in the
varsity analysis i didn't see
like k appear anywhere in the lower
bounds i assume you're hiding some
dependents of the results on the uh
main function just in the computation
the mean being linear is
what do you mean by the mean function
uh the conditional mean of y given x so
in this case that would just be
um you know
the fact that the two coefficients are
the case loss
where does that come
um
i guess um i mean
k is uh sort of smaller than n here
that's that's kind of where we use it uh
apart from that it's it's sort of
it doesn't really
appear anywhere else in some sense
so i guess it's tied to the
coverage that's
um
in fact yeah so i mean
so in fact like the covariance is
designed so that sort of theta star is
non-zero only in the directions where
the covariance is large so we are lying
so theta star is case pass in that top
case of space where the covariance is
large
so so that it's somewhat easier to
recover
so that theta star effectively
so in that way yeah the the theta star
is sort of case fast in the top k
direction
yeah i didn't mention that
in the construction that's how sort of
the test
[Music]
and also for k to be small
the particular
intuition somehow more broadly about the
estimator
suffering from a lack of ability to
spread
right and essentially that's where so
so that's sort of
um
i think if there's uh
yeah i mean essentially that's
where the intuition for the lower bound
sort of comes in so you you kind of have
to so if you think about any estimator
it has to
predict well on
uh
so if you look at the risk if given that
sigma is sort of large in the top three
directions
it kind of has to get
a theta star correct in those top k
directions otherwise it's going to
suffer high excess risk so either
sort of you could predict theta star
well in those top directions otherwise
you suffer high excess risk or you will
have sort of really large directions in
those
in the final d minus k directions which
contribute to the excess risk
i'm not sure if that sort of
answered your question
uh
but yeah happy to chat and sort of go
through it more carefully
any other questions
with regression yeah it seems tricky
because
really i mean
yeah i mean what's what's crucially used
in all of these results are that like
your direction is going off to infinity
uh if your
it seems like technically like a
challenge but actually it's a bone here
in some sense
uh in regression
there are results that say that at least
for some class of losses any relating
schemes fail as you start to interpolate
the data
and and we we thought about it but yeah
we didn't have any good answers to fix
that
today will be at four o'clock
you